reactome also has another tool called
reactome gsa
which allows users to analyze proteomics
transcriptomics and microarray data
data sets from all of these methods can
be combined in a single analysis
thereby reactome gsa can perform
multiomics pathway analyses
its main feature is that it performs
quantitative pathway analyses
the so-called gene set analyses this
increases the statistical power of the
differential expression analysis
which is directly performed on the
pathway level
reactome gsa is integrated into
reactomes data analysis tool suite
in the analyze data interface the input
file must be a tab delimited text file
such as csv or tsv file where the first
column contains the gene or protein
identifiers and all subsequent columns
the respective samples
the first row contains the sample names
and all subsequent rows the genes or
proteins
in the first screen you need to select
the algorithm to use for the
differential pathway analysis
the detailed parameters for each
algorithm can be adapted by clicking the
blue icon on the left of the algorithms
box
padag and camera perform a differential
expression analysis between two groups
of samples
ssgse is a so-called gene set variation
approach
that returns pathway level quantitative
data for each sample
padag stands for pathway analysis with
down weighting of overlapping genes
computes a gene set score based on gene
weights that are designed to emphasize
the genes appearing in few gene sets
versus genes that appear in many gene
sets
inter gene correlations can skew
analysis results
camera or correlation adjusted mean rank
gene set test is based on the idea of
estimating the inter gene correlation
from the data
and using it to adjust the gene set test
statistic
single sample gsea or ssgsea calculates
separate enrichment scores for each
pairing of a sample
and gene set each ssgsea enrichment
score represents the degree to which the
genes in a particular gene set are
coordinately up or down regulated within
a sample
after clicking continue you are
presented with the now empty list of
data sets
click the plus add data set button to
add a new data set
now you have to select the type of data
set you want to load
to upload your own data select one of
the options under select a file from a
local folder
to test the tool it is possible to
quickly load example data
currently react home gsa provides three
example data sets
two matched data sets on melanoma
associated b cells
and one scr and asec data set on b cells
finally it is possible to directly load
data sets from expression atlas
to do so first navigate to expression
atlas in a separate tab or window
once a data set is added you need to
annotate the experimental metadata
this is necessary in order to define the
groups for the differential expression
analysis in the next step
you can adapt the dataset's name in the
dataset name box at the top
this name will be used for all results
to increase the readability
we suggest to use as short names as
possible
to add an annotation click the plus
symbol on the right
this will add a new empty column to the
table
first add a heading to define the name
of the property for example
treatment next add the values for every
sample that you want to include in your
comparisons
samples without any values will simply
be ignored
in the final step of adding a data set
you have to define which groups to
compare
the comparison factor drop-down menu
contains all parameters
that were annotated in the sample table
before
first group and second group define
which groups of samples to compare
against each other
depending on which comparison factor you
select the available values for the
first group and second group will change
automatically
additionally some gene set analysis
methods allow you to define
so-called covariates these are
parameters that might cause a bias in
your result that you would like to
correct for
simply select the relevant ones for your
experiment
once you click continue you will be
returned to the list of data sets where
you will now see your annotated data set
in the list
if you want you can add any number of
data sets to a single request
once you click continue from the data
set list view the final analysis options
are shown
create react home visualizations is
always selected
if it is deselected the result cannot be
visualized in reacton's pathway browser
this option is generally only relevant
to users of the react home gsa
or package if you select create reports
react on gsa will automatically create a
microsoft excel
and pdf report of your results
additionally
it will create a shorter script that
allows you to load your data directly
into inner session
in case you provide your email address
you are automatically notified as soon
as the analysis is complete
the mail will contain direct links to
the generated reports
and a link to the visualization in the
pathway browser
launch the analysis by clicking the go
button
if you provided an email address you can
also close your browser
the analysis will still continue on our
servers and you will be notified as soon
as it is done
some analysis with many large data sets
for example comparing five tcga data
sets in a single analysis
may require up to an hour to complete
reactome gsa analysis calculates up and
down regulation of genes or proteins
based on the submitted data set results
of this analysis are presented similar
to that of over representation with a
few additional elements that are
described below
up and down regulation of genes or
proteins are indicated as arrowheads
pointing up or down respectively
if the value is significant there are
two arrowheads
the analysis tab in the details panel
contains an additional column indicating
if the pathway is up or down regulated
which corresponds to the average value
of all the genes or proteins of that
pathway
the color scale in the diagram panel
that indicates the expression value of
gene
slash proteins is divided into five
categories
significantly upregulated
non-significantly upregulated
not found non-significantly
down-regulated
and significantly down-regulated